So here is some palladium wire. It is a very,
very small
sample of palladium wire. But we will get
it out and see what
we can find out.
Palladium is a material, or an element, that
is quite similar to
platinum so most of these metals, so called
noble metals, or
platinum-group metals are found in South Africa
and they are
the main supplier, the mines in South Africa.
In fact it is so small I can hardly see it.
Palladium is a compound which has recently
become much
more widely used by chemists because palladium
metal and
palladium compounds are used widely in organic
chemistry,
that is the chemistry of carbon compounds,
for joining
different groups together with a bond, two
carbon atoms, the
so called Heck reactions. So most of my colleagues
who do
organic chemistry at some stage or another
employ this
reaction of palladium.
So this is a small sample of palladium. Palladium
is used to
make electrodes; it’s also used for forming
electrical circuits.
It is a very, very, very expensive metal:
it is a precious metal.
It is refined from ores from South Africa,
Australia and also
the former Soviet Republic. The price of palladium
has gone
down recently though, because it is ored with
platinum and
the value of platinum or the demand for platinum
has gone
up because of auto-catalytic converters. Palladium
is used to
catalyse organic reactions but also the electrode
surface in
electro-chemical processes. I’ve got some
other samples of
palladium elsewhere there.
It is also used in the pharmaceutical industry,
but again there
it is not quite such a good reaction because
you have to
remove all traces of palladium from the products
at the end.
So there are other ways that people use it.
In my own work, I
have used, or my students have used, palladium
quite widely
as a catalyst for adding hydrogen to organic
compounds, so
again it’s is one of the elements that’s
have really been quite
good to me.